professor John Nash very welcome to this
interview it's an honor to have you with
us
it has passed sent ten years since you
received the economic price what impact
has it had on your professional and
maybe on your private life over the last
ten years
well it's almost ten years it has had a
tremendous impact on my life more than
on the life of most Prize winners
because I was in a unusual situation I I
was unemployed at the time and I was in
good health I reached the age of 66 and
beginning to get to Social Security but
I didn't have much of that I had many
years of unemployment but for me and so
I it I was in a position to be very much
influenced when ninth the recognition of
my earlier work came about in this way I
had I become widely known but in a sense
it wasn't officially recognized I was
quoted very frequently in the literature
of economics and mathematics but it's
quite difficult to get a official
recognition for in my life did you have
did you have any special memories from
the time 94 when you went to go to
student Escom to receive the price
anything particularly if you would like
to share with us that was well I have
many memories but I I don't know what I
should say it was very remarkable to to
be in in Stockholm in December that's
when the days are getting very short and
I was there for a saying this is the
which is where there's a little
premature celebration of returning life
it's ten days early in fact but you
could see when the these the afternoon
began to getting dark around three
o'clock and so that was really a
phenomenon that I have not observed
before lower latitudes you said in your
speech I believe or maybe it was later
in your biography that you were hoping
by having now we know the age of 66 that
you would achieve much more
professionally do you feel that you have
had the opportunity and the time to do
that or have your time being mainly
taken up by giving lectures or traveling
around being a celebrity there has been
much of my time has been taken up in
that way but I have been making progress
in the other sense I I haven't completed
so much I have a paper published on idea
money which I hope to follow up that
with another paper extending the ideas
and I really feel I've just discovered a
well it's hard to describe it better
there there has been a deterioration and
the quality of money in that's
observable in many areas and it brings
up questions like you could see how
money is different all of a sudden in
Italy when they had the lira and nothing
of the Euro so they in a revolutionary
way have gone from bad money to good
money comparatively but what about the
rest of the world even the dollar is
there some questions around today yeah
what what what it was the dollar used to
be a gold standard currency I mean the
dollar was really good in the last
century I mean in the 19th century found
is very fascinating what just talking
about what are the reasons for this
would you say that the the the quality
of money has sort of changed well it's
complicated I I think we might get into
too much deeper arteries here okay I
don't I don't want to compete with
professor Mandel and in this meeting I'm
going to be listening to him and
learning things when he lectures okay
it's a fascinating subject
oh yes I have other areas of - other is
research on I'm not about to publish and
my work is really relates to game theory
but a project and I haven't other areas
of study I don't know how long I will
live and how long I'll be ever did how
much I would be able to do but at least
I am active I I was thinking that when
you were a child I have spoken to some
of the price witness over the last
couple of years and many of them were
not at all interested in the subject
that they finally got very deep into how
was it for you were you very interested
in maths for example ha or did you feel
that you have a special gift for that I
I did have an appreciation of math and
science as a child and I even elementary
school I would like to do more in
mathematics than the other students
doing in one way or another so I I did
have that in an early stage like maybe
almost comparable to Mozart in music
okay Chrissy we had a father who's
musician was that recognized early at
the early stage in your case you're
special
your talent well no it's recognized my
my parents realized that I was mentally
special and because things things are
loved this is where I live the school
system wasn't really adapted for special
students so there wasn't much to do
except to go through that and then go on
do you think it's better now well there
are maybe special schools for especially
talented children so that one can really
give them what they need
well there are many complicated issues
come in and education I I don't know
that I want express an opinion you have
to have education and in different
locations you you have the cities and
you have the smaller areas it's
represent different problems the
students can reach the level that they
need to reach ultimately and sometimes
if they try to go into it too early
though they might then they don't do so
well finally so I don't know if it
matters so much because the American
education system is very inefficient in
many ways compared to other countries in
Europe or Japan but it works in such a
way that at least the cube leave of her
have her going on to unusual careers and
Sciences can manage to get into that
even though they go through an earlier
stage that doesn't give them much
could was bussiness as a waste of time
at for some oh yes it's like it's like a
babysitter's sort of like you have
kindergarten when it should be the
elementary school you were very young
when you made your discovery that you
were given the price for what was the
breakthrough for you when you were
looking into that problem and and how
did you I mean briefly how did you
realize what you were you know achieving
at the time well there were special
circumstances and with regard to the
what's called the Nash equilibrium and
that's the name cited topic I happen to
be a graduate student in Princeton and
Venoy Minh and Marcin were residents of
Princeton and they had written the book
theory of games and economic behavior
which in turn depended on some earlier
work in France email burrell and then
going back even to people like pierre de
firma and pascal and who studied
fallibilities
and
so I had the opportunity to describe
something different from the procedure
in phenomena Morgenstern and I I wrote
it out but I could I could use much of
their ideas their concept of strategies
and utility part of which in themselves
that had been adopted from previous
study by Burrell and so I could I could
develop this thing is first called
accordion points in in-person games and
then non-cooperative games was my final
thesis titled and so it was very
fortunate that I happened to be in that
location there was a seminar at the
University that was concerned with work
relating to the work of a Norman
Morrison so everything went together and
I had also some other work relating to
economics which linked in this is what
to come the bargaining problem and that
is also important but it wasn't cited
for the Nobel Prize because I was linked
with also with Hasani insulting and the
prize and they were not everything to
must see with the the equilibrium comes
in and I really want to think but her
son he also had done work in the
bargaining the collaborative games and
zultan has done work in the experimental
games and he would talk on that here in
this meeting
did you realize at the time how big this
discovery was the way you had well I
knew I had a good idea
it was well worth publishing in its
Arabic expanded it on the phenomena - in
the zero-sum game which of course van
orman himself had done originally but I
it's hard to know what were what will
come up something out the future will be
and of course as far as Nobel Prize at
that time there was nothing in economics
so one couldn't look forward to that so
that to me in 68 you study does so that
is entirely in matters and the frictions
if you were to give advice to young
students today what feeds should they
look into if they are interested in
economics in economics well it with
regard to the specific subfields of
economics
I don't know so well I I can observe
that game theory is is applied very much
an economic said it would be I would say
when in general that would be it would
be wise to get into the mathematics as
much as as much as seems reasonable and
because the economists suit who uses
more mathematics somehow are more
respected than those who use less that's
the trend and I don't think exactly like
a professional economist I think about
he cannot economics and you can on the
Caddy's but somewhat like an outsider
of course the lineman was not an
economist but Morrison was and they
teamed together on that
and otherwise there are a lot of trends
than you can onyx what seems what seems
fashionable now and the general opinion
might be quite different after 20 years
or so if someone is starting a career
they should be prepared for changes I
think that should learn things that are
good foundations but don't necessarily
depend on the current fashion or what
the Greek is our general opinion the
popular opinion should maybe try to
learn things that it would be good for
all time unquestionable scientific value
are there any issues in the world today
if that that you are may that you are
concerned of for example if we look at
the disparity between the first
so-called first world and third world
if we look at the political situation
and what's come comes with it for
example the u.s. budget does a budget
deficit and it's reasons for that are
there any of those issues that you that
concerns you as a scientist and that you
give extra sauce
well you mentioned some different things
like the question of the first world
world and but on to the second world and
the u.s. budget does are quite different
topics certainly they offer this broad
spend I think they require different
doctors is anything that you are
particularly concerned of well these are
popular themes but you find something
that people are talking about and you
you may find that there are differing
opinions
there's the the most widely held opinion
but there may be some other opinion that
is more scientific or by subtle but it
is easy to to say that there are the
rich and the poor and so something
should be done but in history there
they're always the rich of the poorest
if the the poor were not a sport
he was so common for I mean whoever has
as less can we call the poor you will
always have the 10% that have less and
the 10% that have the most but they may
be comparatively the nuts of them I was
thinking about these things when I saw
India for the first time in it was last
year in January 2003 when driving
through the countryside of India I could
see you as where presumably the amount
of recognized income personal income
would be very low but this gave me the
thought a comparatively one sort of
peasant level Union and another one
might not feel so bad these are not the
beggars on the street about people out
of the country if they have as much as
someone else in that area if they are
not so poor compared to their neighbors
and if you look through history humans
have lived under different conditions
they had to live and maybe very very
primitive Lee a few thousand years ago
so much of this living of the modern
humans is very very recent man
existed for much longer than has this
technology am I thinking from what
you're saying you know it's really
comparative you know how much you need
and there is a certain idea maybe in
their so-called Western world that we
need more than we actually do need is a
certain greed which is kind of taking
resources from from third so-called
third world countries is that I mean do
we you know there's a bleed wealth does
it lead to
wishes are further wealth or or you know
which is maybe I'm when the the the the
more that the the richer countries if
they if they wish to consume more this
is likely to provide some some business
for other parts of the world they would
have maybe some imports I mean if if
countries like the USA and Sweden are to
import more then that is business for
other parts of the world and maybe some
some choice products that what makes it
hard for the others right the world if
if the countries again like USA a Sweden
can manufacture all that I need in
manufactured goods and furthermore
produce all they need I could culturally
so they don't need to import anything
and they have things to exploit yeah
that's partly where we are today on
isn't it I mean they're the issues there
is a political issue about these
subsidies for agriculture that European
countries which could import agriculture
products with was subsidized local
agriculture and and maybe in produce the
products I'd like the Germany maybe
growing us a lot of wheat which they we
make it approach and they might it might
be they wouldn't need to grow any he
take
imported from Russia or somewhere and
and then that would provide business
right trade may may I come to a question
that you must choose to also whether you
like or not because I think as many
people know at least two films and one
book has been written about your life
one documentary film okay and then a
book which was the basis for the film I
believe that's right it was partly
concentrating on terms which were very
difficult in your life or concentrating
on that and how do you feel about that
version of your life that came across to
the public and do you feel that there is
it necessary for you to in any way
comment on that today or is it something
that is something that you left behind
Ruby the movie the movie is easier to
come in on well the movie of course the
family of these we received some money
for cooperating and authorizing the
movie the movie is in part an
interpretation of how a case of mental
illness can go odd can could could be
the nature of the case and how it could
evolve because most typically what you
call mental illness or what can be
called schizophrenia has an unfavorable
course of history in the sense that the
people never really recovered to be what
you could call mentally well
they they become like what are called
consumers of mental health organization
they are always taking some sort of a
pill they likely are not in hospital C
they get all of hospitals but they they
live in a form of life that's for people
who are not really highly functional
they're not functional they're not
really in the economy of self-supporting
people they didn't not living a normal
life from the economic point of view and
they so in in my case there was
certainly recovery of sanity and more
possibility of doing normal activities
and so it was an interesting case and I
was and I'm not a mental patient now I
don't take any medicine but I have a son
who unfortunately is an inefficient and
in the process of me taking drugs and
seeing psychiatrist this sort of thing
we don't know what the course of that
would be but it was a I was disturbed in
this way for a very long period of time
like 25 years in sort of a starting
around 30 so it was quite a portion of
life history teeth and that the movie
the movie gives an insight into how this
sort of thing can go the movie actually
at the end of it they have the it
suggests that the the person in the
movie is still taking some medicine and
taking a modern type of a drug after he
had tried not to take it in it struggled
with for easier taking so there's a
difference that we the directory in in
the movie we didn't want to suggest
people who are living in the states
with control Jimena know that they
should top stopped taking their medicine
they go it would be dangerous to suggest
this okay so it doesn't correspond to me
accurately so where they've been many
years I haven't had medicine since 1970
that's 35 years well more than 30 years
is it is it important for you as before
that most of the time I didn't really
take the medicine so the different types
of course it's not the same but a film
which was so widely seen and I was
thinking that it has it been important
for you to be able to give your version
of your life as well or is it something
that you feel you can you know because
when somebody goes in and make a film
about somebody's life then you know you
might need to say over
that's the film but the reality is a
little bit is artistic it doesn't
describe accurately the nature of the
delusional thinking that was my history
and it's interpret like it has someone
who sees imaginary persons sees that as
if persons are actually present the eruv
made and that is not a that's not even
typical in schizophrenia so but that
interprets the idea of divisions more
typically a person may hear voices
they're talking with spirits or
something which are not there this is
the problem of more typical delusions
but you can't illustrate that in the
movie very well when the movie shows
someone who can be seen then the
difference of seeing the movie can
better understand it this can occur in
mental illness but it's the less typical
form it's fascinating to talk to you and
I'm really really happy that you have
spoken to us today is there any concerns
I was talking earlier about young
students and somebody said to me that
you know the teachers are those who are
open up doors but other students who
have to walk through them themselves did
you have any teacher through your period
at university which was particularly a
role model to you or or how has it been
for you
I certainly had some good teachers who
were very helpful to me and influential
and for example in economics I only took
one economics course and that was I was
in the undergraduate study in Pittsburgh
but it's not called Carnegie Mellon
but by coincidence the person who taught
the course I took it was a course in
international economics and I Quincy but
this was someone who came from Austria
so and that's actually what to consider
Austrian economics is like a different
school than typical American British so
I I was by coincidence influenced by an
Austrian economist which may be a very
good influence well thank you so much I
will enjoy very much to be able to
listen through when with the student
discussions are going on as well enjoy
Linda very much
thank you for offensive thank you